it was done no signal okay good morning
yes away the topic of this talk is no
signalling proofs I'm gonna explain what
it is and the result would we show is
that any no signaling proof with at most
square root log and provers or order
square log and provers is in p space so
I'll join what it is this is joint work
with the student from MIT D Raj Holden I
wish he was here to get the talk but
unfortunately for you it's me so okay so
let's start so wait the proof system
we're gonna proof model we're going to
consider today is that of multi prover
interactive proofs so in a multi so this
notion was introduced by a Ben over the
selenium Victor zone and a this proof
model really is kind of gave the birth
to PCP it's a very influential proof
model and here there's two provers that
are soon not to interact a and it was
inspired by the goal was to get zero
knowledge or information third it's your
knowledge but what was really surprising
what was shown a few years after was
introduced by by by photo alone is that
this is a very very powerful proof
system namely you can prove any language
in X you assuming you have to prove errs
that do not interact okay but the power
of this proof system really stems from
the fact that these provers do not
interact at all they behave completely
locally and you can think about it the
reason this is so powerful it's very
hard to cheat in this model because if
you're a cheater you need to cheat in a
way that's consistent and essentially
that's how these are proofs work the
verify tries to check if a consistency
and it's very hard to consider to cheat
in a consistent manner okay what we're
going to talk today is about a different
cheating strategy as opposed to allowing
the provers only restricting them to
behave completely locally so I could
prove her one can only answer the query
1 over 2 only 2 query 2 we're going to
consider what's
no signaling strategies so now sibling
strategies were introduced in the
context of quantum mechanics and in a
new signaling strategy the provers can
actually interact okay so actually the
pro-morsi both queries but their hands
are tied okay they say both queries
however proven one answer even though he
sees the other query should not if you
see the answer it should not signal any
information about what the other query
is so let me explain this a little more
formally so in a no signaling strategy
no matter what query Hoover one gets q1
for any two other queries that prove our
two gets the distribution of his answer
so the distribution of the answer
restricted to q1 is the same it's the
same whether the other query is q2 or q2
Prime it's exactly the same distribution
so if you look at this stare at it for a
second you may think okay I'm giving him
both queries but I'm not allowing him to
use the other query so isn't it the same
as being local and indeed actually if
you think of the cheating prove or P
star is being deterministic which is how
we coped ographers tend to think of
cheating approvers because we typically
use the non uniform model in which case
with hours of generality you can assume
that the provers are deterministic if
you think as P star is deterministic
then you're right actually it's like no
signaling strategy and being classical
is the same because as I said leave the
tribution and this is the same but it's
not a distribution it's it's it's a
deterministic so means answer have to be
the same so then so can dependent and q2
but the power of this no signaling model
is stems from the fact that the P star
can actually be randomized and even
though when you look at it now you may
think okay you randomized but still what
can he do
better than being deterministic turns
out he can and we're going to expand on
this in a bit
doesn't have deterministic strategy the
holistic good question I don't know of
any connection there's no boroughs
theorems or you know fixed point
theorems hiding here or anything it's
actually more connected to quantum and
I'll get to it in a minute
well quantum also kind of the power of
quantum is when you measure there is
randomness kind of in there that's okay
so more generally we define no saline
for K provers similar to the classical I
might puke and think of an K prover
setting and in the K prover setting the
requirement extends in a natural way in
other words for every subset s of the
provers for any two vectors of queries
that are green s okay so the subset of s
provers get the same queries the
distributions of their answer should be
the same no matter what the other
queries are so extend exactly in the
same way okay so any questions about the
definition it's a good question why I'm
interested in it which I'll explain in a
bit but about the definition itself okay
so one question that you oh yes think
for any it doesn't matter I won't say
for any subset of s there in the
distribution of their answer is the same
no matter what the other queries are
that's the definition no not given the
answer just just given all if you look
at for any Q and Q prime if you a look
at the answers given the G of the no
signaling strategy of the P star and s
whether it's given Q or whether it's
given Q prime the vector cure the vector
Q prime if Q and Q prime agree on s so
they get the same queries they give the
same answer distribution wise their
distribution is the same yes and they
will be because you know the other
provers the answer
the Q Prime in there according to Q and
Q and Q prime are different so the
answer will be different any questions
about the definition I am allowed to
look at the other questions yes exactly
you're allowed to look you see all the
queries but your distribution on your
answers for any subset should not the
distribution should be exactly the same
so you cannot weigh it seem like I can't
do anything with it you can only look
but you can't act on it in a sense but
my distribution of answers can be
different for each pair Q Q Prime right
they mean it so if the if the the
question of the other proofer is
different than my distribution can
change no look this distribution and
this distribution is the same right for
any Q Prime that agree honest so the
distribution really only depends on Q
sub s and the query is restricted to the
set s so there seems maybe it's an order
quantifier thing but it looks like the
distribution is allowed to depend on you
fixed Q and Q Prime and then you get the
distribution but because you're right
but because it holds for every Q and Q
Prime
if you you call this kind of
distribution I don't know some of it
it's all the same it only depends on Q
sub s okay so I allow you to see but in
the sense I don't allow you to act on it
so it seems like it's not more powerful
maybe but that's an incorrect intuition
it is more powerful as we will see okay
so first thing I want to say is you may
be kind of puzzled why am i explaining
the two pover then yes you would
what why we study next slide I'm gonna
explain why we study why we study in the
next slide intubation
no we're not setting I have to prove us
and are completely separate they don't
see the two queries no just one see the
query yes exactly
precisely yes yes yes no they can have
sheer randomness ahead of them
yes they can be yeah okay so first I
just want to point out before I give I'm
gonna spend a lot of time telling you
why I think this is interesting notion
but I just want to say many of you know
that actually in the classical setting
Kay prover it can be reduced a to prefer
that was shown in the seminal work on
that introduced to know the concept of
multi proven tractive proofs so you may
think why am i why do I need to define
both the kay party setting the Cape
Hoover setting and the to prove her
senses that this does not extend in the
no singling setting in the no signal
setting looking at K provision in two
approvers is not the same thing and
we'll see actually a result kind of to
this effect okay are actually trying to
get a path like doing a conversion in
some meaningful manner but we'll see
that later okay so two Chevy's question
why do we care so I defined this notion
and it seems a little bit like okay kind
of very similar to classical in a sense
even though I'm letting you see that
aquarium not really letting you kind of
depend on it in any way so and why do we
care about it yes it's essentially yes
MIP usually multiple inductive proof get
a query answer no rounds just one yes
that's usually how we think of this
model it's also in the no signal setting
equivalent
you know in the note well you can add
provers and then it becomes equivalent
yes you can always replace rounds by
more approvers okay so now let me try to
convince you that this model is very
interesting I'm very interested in it
for many reasons and maybe you'll even
help me find more reasons so I'm gonna
give you three motivations for this
model the first one is the original
motivation which is comes from quantum
from quantum strategies and then I'm
going to give you two other applications
one is the delegation of computation and
the other one - hardness of
approximation so let's see these are a
motivation to understand they don't
really see the queries they see enough
so that they can that this is a
restriction on what they can do so
exactly so less so let me explain so in
the classical setting that you know was
where the MIP was introduced they did
not allow any approvers to kind of share
in pingos state and so on
they were classic approvers in that you
know they're completely local all you
see is q1 you don't have some entangled
with other provers complete locality
that was the assumption in the original
paper and then there was a paper of
Cleveland who argued well and why why
was it okay to say that assume that
you're local so the motivation was well
you put the to prove or than different
rules or you know far apart and so they
can't interact okay so it seemed like a
reasonable assumption the classical
setting is the probabilistic it's not
you can be probably stick all-powerful
but the entire stock here there's no
crypto everybody the cheating provers
are all to be all powerful exactly it's
all about seeing the queries exactly so
cliff it'll ask the question well even
if they're far away they may share
quantum entanglement so if the cheating
provers share quantum entanglement now
they don't actually act locally even if
they're far apart so the locality
condition actually breaks down if you
allow quantum entanglement and in that
setting what happens that was their
question and what they showed is
actually there are examples of
my piece for which the quantum
strategies outperform all classical
strategies so you can do better okay and
so maybe especially today and notes in
the quantum and you know computers are
kind of approaching us we should
consider you know the quantum setting
and no signaling strategies is a
generalization of quantum strategies so
if you are no signaling you cannot if
you're pointing in particular you're no
signaling actually no signaling allows
you to do whatever you want
quantum whatever I give you both queries
you have only one restriction and the
only restriction I'm giving you is
essentially you can't transfer
information like your answer can't kind
of be a proof that actually information
was transferred from there from other
queries and this is just a consequence
of special relativity theory okay so
it's it only assumes essentially this
model of cheating prove ourselves you
know what that cheating provers can have
quantum can have whatever they want the
only thing I'm assuming is a special
relativity theory holds that's kind of
how you should think about it and
therefore it's also you know we know
that quantum mechanics is not a complete
theory so the ideas you know I don't
know what theory of physics we're gonna
come up with as long as you can't you
know transfer information to your
ancestors this model is strong enough
okay that's kind of so it's a very
strong model and it's a clean model it's
a nice mathematical model and that's why
physicists like like to study it okay
but more down-to-earth to us into this
workshop what I think more relevant is
the connection to delegation and what so
there's a very beautiful heuristic that
called the periodic refugee heuristic by
Bill Maher in Wetzel and what they
propose they said you don't take any MIP
so think of to prove us let's say MIP
and convert it to a delegation scheme so
take two person it to just one prover
how using crypto so in the language of
encryption overlay morphic encryption
the way you wish it you should think
about it is they suggested instead of
giving to query queries to different
provers give it
the same Hoover but encrypted using
different keys fresh keys and the prover
will kind of do the computation under
the hood of the encryption and give the
answers okay so this was a heuristic
from the late 1990s and the question is
its own so if you start with an MIP that
it's secure that its sound is this sound
assuming the encryption is sound and
what we showed with the horn in Vanguard
is that it's sound if there might be has
no signaling soundness this is actually
there's no point of you know it just
says if if it's no signalling soundness
holds in the MIP then this is sound and
we constructed an MIP with no seven
sonnets and therefore no sound was used
to get delegation you need the folio
most encryption exactly at the
computational peer scheme is enough
because you can kind of generate a
database for all the possible answers of
the queries and then it's like so it's
enough but it's easier to think about in
terms of fhe the the other like if you
have an attack an on signal attack can
you break this delegation very good so
good so you can say okay no signaling it
works but maybe also without noticing it
also works that begs the question and
the answer is no actually we know of it
so this is a paper it started this work
started in people by doggett al and
later by Dodie settle who showed that
actually in general it's not sound so if
you don't work what they gave examples
of m IPS that are not secure against no
signaling that you can break with an O
single attack for which this is not
secure anymore
and actually it seems like us on the
proofs there's some barrier it seems
like if this is not secured against no
signalling attack if you can cheat in a
no single attack it seems like at least
there's no black back proof that this is
secure so it seems like really in order
what what when you encrypt when you
encrypt something you can't assume that
he behaves locally the only thing that
encryption buys you is that this prefer
behaviour in a no signalling manner that
the only thing you can get from this so
really what this line of work shows is
that actually encryption is really goals
it's very similar to no signalling that
kind of did what encryption buys you is
that it's no signalling yes
no not any specific one but the world to
be natural much as positive application
it's not a good checkpoint any quite any
more questions okay so let's go to the
last application and the last
application is two hardness of
approximation and they're what we showed
is how to use no signaling to get
hardness of approximation for space
so before PT peas or MI peas were used
to get Hardison approximation of time we
showed that the no signaling MIP or PCP
to leave it that way too can be used to
get hardness of approximation of space
in particular what we showed is there
exists a fixed polyhedron fixed such
that approximating linear program with
this specific polyhedron it's be
complete with respect to poly log space
reduction so let me explain a little
better what this means let me parse this
theorem at this a joint work with say a
housing I gave so what we showed is that
there exists one fixed polyhedron this
polyhedron essentially contains all no
signaling strategies and what we showed
is that for any language in P whether X
is in the language or not can be so this
statement can be converted into a linear
program said that if it's in the
language the values one if it's not in
the language the value is negligible and
this reduction is poly log space and
what this means is if you can
approximate this in little space then
all of you can do with long space and we
don't believe that's the case so as long
as you can P is not you know small space
then even solving telling linear program
with this specific polyhedron even if
you have like pre-processing time and
this polyhedron as much as you want cuz
it's fixed is approximating it needs you
need a lot of space to approximate yes
hey this is a no signal strategy it's um
it's not a specific game no and no
singing strategy just means you know so
for every okay essentially for every set
of queries you have a probability
distribution and the probability of this
women should satisfy this no singling
condition so it has nothing to do with
the game it's just kind of the condition
of what it means to be no signaling
though the definition that we saw before
word know something means it can be
translated into a polyhedron so let me
just mention this was known previously
when the polyhedron was not fixed but if
you allow pre-press and the polyhedron
it was completely broken so we showed
that's the case so if the polyhedron is
not fixed you don't need no signalling
but for a fixed polyhedron we know how
to do it using no signal
yeah so essentially yeah so what what's
going on here it's I want to know if X
is in the language I have a no singling
MIP for for P and this no single item ap
I so I want to know what is the maximum
probability of accepting this MIP with a
no singing strategy this is kind of the
maximum probability of accepting this
MIP constraint on the north the strategy
being no signaling in that kind of the
constraint this is the constraint of
polyhedron of being no signaling yeah I
didn't explain this is kind of a you
know talk of its own but I just wanted
to give a little okay so again we talked
about three applications to quantum to
no signaling hardness of approximation
and now kind of it begs the question
what is the power of these proof systems
okay what is the power of no signal inga
strategy so we you know it for local
it's next
you don't hear you don't see them okay
so it's a-okay so it's good yes exactly
it's a dimension of the polyhedron so
essentially it would way to think about
it we know that whether X is in the
language or not there's an MIP
corresponding to it and we can think of
whether the we can think of each no
signaling strategy as a point in this
polyhedron and the maximum probability
of acceptance of this no singing
strategies can be written as just an
inner product like that I didn't explain
how exact einde of any word that you can
say where does the non signalling comes
in yeah because okay uh-oh as opposed to
local if you're local you won't be a
polyhedron the local condition will not
satisfy a linear program a constraint of
a polyhedron you yeah it's gonna be
exactly you can't describe it described
as a polyhedron yes okay thanks Jaffe
that was actually good yeah so the
reason you need no signaling is opposed
to locals because if you're local you
can't describe this as a polyhedron the
space of strategies is not a polyhedron
something that's been used anywhere else
this is the strategy
pounding the power of the exact showing
the Sigma is an excellent one oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah good yes yeah yeah yeah
I'm gonna go yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
okay so now I understand the question
yes dancers if they let me I'll get to
it in next slide
chef you're like always one-sided which
is great okay so so what is the power of
these no signature so the question is do
these know sit by allowing you to see
both queries but tying your hand
do you have more path do you actually
have more power maybe maybe no so here's
what's known
okay so first first set of results by
campaign talent by a total say that and
let it contains pspace okay now we know
even one four row contains pspace so you
don't even need to but because this is
only one round going back to Andy's
question interactive proof is many round
here it's only one round was to only two
parties so this is a meaningful result
and they showed leaflet contains pspace
okay but the question is does it contain
all of next right that's kind of what we
want to know yeah basically yeah if I
have two independent things then they
satisfied its distribution there I ever
joined distribution which is essentially
Cartesian protocol two independently
I get no signaling yes
there's no signal think there's not that
must be the no signaling does not imply
that I can give you a joint distribution
that the marginals are look looking
independent yes yes if you're
conditioned on any know you gather is
independent yeah but it's not good so
you're right and you you're totally
right you're saying clearly it's more
powerful and you're right
the question is can you use it to get
better can to win better and there might
be okay you can have a joint joint is
more joint is more the question is does
this more buy you anything because it's
more but if you like this more is kind
of not I'm trying
hands a little bit so does it by you ot
your CHS age or whatever where you can
actually see that where no signaling
buys you right you're right then
actually so actually before we talk
about it too much
of course it binds you because with if
you allow them cheating prefers to be no
signaling now you can't do all of next
you can only do expert so assuming the
next by next for not the same
I can this already shows that you know
no signal energies are powerful okay
because if I allowed to be to do no
signaling any MIT before for language
annexed now you can cheat and
essentially the reason this kind of go
back to the toughest question is that
the reason it's an X I don't actually
who to attributed it I think it's kind
of full claw or who Oh they showed it
okay in their paper okay so a so that
that reference thinks so what what's
known is that the value of a no
signaling MIP can actually be computed
by a linear programming you can convert
this MIP to a linear programming and are
you can if it's in the language it's a
septal proble t1 it's not only which is
so with very small probability and
approximating the valuation program we
can do in you know time that's
phenomenal in the linear programming so
that's why it's an it's X my polyhedral
from before
exactly exactly that's why you can use
it as a linear programming exactly
okay so what do we know we know it's
between pspace and Expo but now what is
it is it P space or is it X okay so
here's what what was known so it all
showed that if you restrict the no scent
only two pruners it's P space and with
one in hand we showed that if you allow
poly n provers then it's all of X by the
way in the abstract I think it has been
updated but there was a typo that said
poly log because I would think of the
scaled-down version so if you read the
abstract kind of try to erase it and you
can read it again Hey okay so um so so
what we know if you have a two prefers P
space many provers X now the question is
what's in between ok the visit can you
push the expert a three can you okay and
and the reason we were interested in
this question partly is because if you
were able to push this further you would
get better hardness of approximation for
example results so so that was kind of
one of the reasons we ask this question
but people in the quantum community have
been asking this question as well and
just wanting to understand the power of
these proof systems and what we show is
that up to at least order log n it's
pspace okay so all the way from log and
provers unless you can only do p space
if you have many proverbs you can do ax
and kind of this part in between it's
still open
hey movie
hey okay yes summation some bound
conditional bound on the other side like
that if you can do sublinear then it
will give you something and plausible
for you know you'll be able to solve P
and small space or something like that
is there like a summer Jean right
because it turns the fewer provers it
reduces the dimension of your of your
linear program like so it's it's more
than its I don't know but it's more it's
more delicate than what you say because
the linear freedom also the linear
program also goes grows with the answer
and query size not just with a number of
Hoover's so that question is okay that's
not the only problem it's not the only
parameter it's a bit more complex here
okay so so this is a result yes okay so
you're again also it looks like but good
so this is assuming the alphabet is poly
okay I'm in the regime of you know MIP
the verifier is polynomial time you can
do any communication that's polynomial
time that the standard kind of
complexity theory modeling right but in
this workshop we're interested really in
P and you know we want communication to
be bounded and we're you know in
real-world efficiency land and so on so
forth so one can ask okay but when we
move down to P what is what are your
results showing you went to like we're
real-world efficiency I don't care about
X but I'm not proving things in expert
so let's try to translate this result
it's a kind of the scaled down version
and in the scaled down version just the
kind of calibrate what what's known is
so now I'm kind of saying the same thing
but kind of in a more scaled-down
version that to approval no signaling
when the communication is small it
corresponds to bounded space and the
space essentially depends on the
communication okay so essentially
communication as corresponds to space s
but roughly speaking okay
and what we showed with on and on is
poly log provers you can do all of P and
what our results now are showing that
also square root log and provers or
order square root log and provers is
also bounded space and the bound again
depends on the communication complexity
okay so if their total communication is
C then the space kind of depends goes
with this
and we just replace no no it's not log
log it's not log dog it's log in it
doesn't scale down with log one yeah
doesn't and maybe one will see and the
proof you'll see why didn't become know
so here it's only to prove us right it
doesn't relate to the number of provers
bound it's me that relates to the
communication complexity so if you think
of IP in the same thing with to prove
earn on signalling it's the same why it
can't you do all of P using an
interactive proof well of course you can
you can do P space over of course P but
if the communication is small say poly
log we don't think you can do P because
2 to the poly monger big because we
don't believe that P can be because IP
it's our IP with public communication is
essentially like poly log space
essentially active poly it's almost the
same yeah
you should think of it up the poly
factors there's the same so if you want
poly log communication it's like being
in part in space poly log and therefore
it's not P yes what when the
communication is smaller exactly you the
communication what you what you answer
is a partition on the probability space
without less partition you can you
cannot then take advantage of the of the
joint disturb you you have an advantage
here of joint distribution the
refinement of the probability space
laughter by doing
yes one analyst question about the query
exercises so the mark style you know
exponential space for the queries with
constant constant Coover's but like huge
query space does it so as long as the
size of the query so you're kind of back
in the previous ya know so all all it's
saying is essentially that with if the
number of provers is small enough then
essentially you're the space is bound
with bellevue communication complexity
that's all
in both cases when but in the previous
slide the concretion codebook is big so
impede space if you care about being
kind of verified very efficient the
mutations are small then you're less
than p space in which case you're really
not in P but the scale up and scale down
are really the same it essentially both
both scales say that the at least from
log N squared log in hours are from
square log in and below it just says
look in the power is like it's it's
bounded by the Khmer Sinha what
communication complexity it won't roll
out if you think exactly I don't know
it's a good ok so way I don't know there
is a good question whether you can still
get better hardness of approximation
using this but definitely not kind of
the trivial way that you know we were
thinking like if if we can get if we
could have gotten here three query three
provers in a natural way whatever that
means
then I think we would have done kind of
for free hardness of approximation and
now really not clear
okay so good so so now then that when
you think of Peter of course the gap
became much smaller so from square log
and we're bounded space for poly log
it's P and now the question is kind of
what's in between okay so let me say
what our results are a bit more formally
so what we show is that if you want any
K prover if you want to come up any any
K prover MIP if you want require the
sound is to be smaller then 1 over 2 to
the K squared you can see why would I
want well if you want the sounds to be
smaller than this then you're stuck in
space 2 to the K squared
yes we need this application -
approximation like there may be it's
enough to get by with constant soundness
Chris here if you set K to be constant
you will get but we don't ya know I see
what you're saying you're yes but you're
right you're right you're saying okay so
it doesn't rule out hard continued okay
you have a very good point what you're
saying this doesn't rule out that maybe
you can come up with the hardness of
approximation because Wireless
approximation you just need constant
soundness you're right but so you're
right that it doesn't rule out when the
other hand because we don't have a
construction we don't have I don't I'm
not cannot also giving you a constant
ya know it you know it's it's a good
question but what you're saying maybe
there is a way I need to take it off to
think about it so I'll table that
question whether because the so the
question of violets a very very good
question
maybe they're stories that maybe even
though what we get is that didn't give
what we want maybe there's still
application to the harness approximation
I need to think about that okay
so okay this may look like a very small
Sounders you say why would we want to
just know Samus and the reason is don't
forget K can be three okay so who are in
the regime where the question is so in
particular
oh one thing I want to say before I
continue sorry I'm awaiting here
constants okay so the actual theorem in
throughout this slide because if I don't
omit it became very messy decides so
every time it's a sound as this it means
there exists a constant C such that if
you require someone less than 2 to the
minus 3 times then in space Pauline this
for some poly so there's always constant
and that's why I'm just not talking
about them okay throughout the talk good
no no and Justin and Lisa actually last
year showed a really nice they're very
nice paper where they have to show the
counter example saying there is no
parallel I mean no not-not-not black box
not just taking that if you just take
the note signaling and repeat it you can
it doesn't have a physalis you can try
to think of amplifying sounds in a
different way by yeah but peral petition
doesn't work reduction is wasteful I
mean doesn't
Oh to traverse many provers what they
show example that no matter how far you
go from any was tuck in the constant it
doesn't do it at all like after what
from the way is you're the conduit for
three right for three talk about
parallel repetition we're talking about
something that's trying to make increase
alphabet size but not increase the
number of queries with PC peas if you
just want to repeat the thing and
increase the number of queries it's easy
to do parallel right also here also here
if you work with increase the number of
provers then it's like sequential
repetition then it does go down also
tell us something about that or no
because if you can okay so now you can
take you can increase the number of
provers by 2 to the K squared okay so
let me just go kind of relate this to
what we talked before so know that if K
is smaller than square of log n what
this theorem is saying is even if you
want on this one over power which is
usually what we were you know we could
toggle for is one negligible service so
the one thumbs one of our power you're
stuck in P space
okay so that's how you should think
about it and you're right that you know
we can't have you know sometimes we
think of oh let's have content third
versus completeness 2/3 and the reason
we say these kind of arbitrary number
third and 2/3 is because we can amplify
them kind of tip the edges but in all
signaling we don't know how to do that
so we actually need to talk about with
you know we're on completeness close to
why didn't you want telling this close
to zero so questions about the main
theorem you know it doesn't matter but I
do need close to poor I need one -
negligible so the way we get this
theorem the way we prove it and which is
kind of a more general theorem at you I
should say that we have is actually a
proven reduction theorem okay what we
actually show is that you can go from K
provers to two poopers we can reduce
exactly like in the classical setting
but not exactly and the reason not
exactly is because we have a big loss
and what is our loss we say if you start
with K prover where the soundness is
small you can cheat us probably at most
with the minus K squared when you go to
to prove errs now cannot reach it with
pretty high probability 1 minus 1 over 2
to the K squared now in the to presume
you have parallel repetition so you can
ample you can make this small but you'll
need to repeat it 2 to the K squared 2
to the K squared times which is huge
okay and this by the way you can use
more refined version of Ito's theorem of
that to prove written pspace a more
refined version of that says that such a
to program IP is actually in space 2 to
the K squared so if you this yes
parallel petition works yeah yes just
like classical completeness but I meant
here is it no signal to yes well it's a
completeness is the same because it's
well I mean it's not so classical
completeness woman is negligible implies
no singling complete this one -
negligible because the completeness just
so you're honest right so if you're
saying do it yeah so we always assume
that actually the MIP the honest provers
are classical we don't think of the cut
of the honest setting as being annoying
okay so showing this proofer reduction
is enough right cuz if you show the
spoon reduction it means that K program
ap you gota to prove er like this and
it'll show that these two provers is in
space 2 to the K squared so from now on
we're going to just focus on trying to
do this prove a reduction
okay any questions
okay so here's the main idea the idea so
that in a nutshell okay the idea is the
following we we do it by going to uh
considering a moral even a more relaxed
version the no signaling okay so know
something was much more powerful right
he got to see both put all the queries
but needed to be no signalling now I'm
giving him even more power
okay he gets to see all the queries and
even be somewhat signaling a little bit
that's called sub no signaling it was
introduced by paper a valencian in
winter in the context of para repetition
and so we consider these types of more
powerful strategies and the main kind of
technical piece of our work that we'll
use in order to get our main result is
we show how to go from some low
signaling if so if you can cheat with a
some no singing strategy we show that
you can also treat with a no signaling
strategy but with a big loss
so do we show any K player game that you
has a sub no singling value close to 1 1
minus 2 to the minus K squared has a no
signaling value at least - mm - K
squared now I probably have confused you
when I said this theorem because I
changed the vocabulary on you here
before we talked about multi proven
interactive proofs and my piece in
abandoning soundness and he also talked
about games and no singling values so I
just want to say both are common in the
literature's we cooked ographers use
usually MIP and soundness but often we
when we think of the MIP for a fixed X
so like a fix that maybe not for a
language but just a fixed kind of for a
fixed input then often it we think about
of the game okay so it's it's just a
game the very first question in the
approver give answer in the value is the
best strategy what what the probability
that you're accepted essentially using
the best of no signal strategy or the
best no signaling strategy so that's
kind of very common terminology in the
literature
okay so again we show if
you can cheat I never give an input if
you can convince a verifier to accept
with probability close to 1 at least 1
minus 2 to the 1 over 2 to the K squared
then you can also choose with a no
signaling strategy but only with
probability 1 over 2 to the K squared so
there is a big loss here ok and and this
this is kind of why are the K squared
here if it was K we would get a log in
as opposed to square log n so it's this
kind of annoying squared that you
probably wouldn't expect it to be much
better than King because of sequential
repetition I would expect if I had to
guess the correct answer is log it's not
the square but that's my religious
belief I don't really have much this
nice thing is that you wouldn't expect
it to be better than K because that
believed to some sort of yeah I wouldn't
explain it to be better than K you're
right yes constant no no yeah hey I
think this one is fine yeah another
thing actually one of them I don't know
because we inherent it from the work of
Lisa and Justin and I don't know what
your constant is so I don't have to know
what the constants are you know we'll
get the better yes this is good about
definitive proof that power repetition
of multiplayer games is what if it has
worked on you oh you think can you think
of this as a proof
hey whatever some extent yes I think so
you can think about that yeah okay so
maybe I'll say a word about what this
sub no signaling strategies are so so
the sub listening strategies are
essentially so let's first recall I want
to say what no singing strategies are
that we defined it before but a little
different terminology that will be more
helpful to define some new signalling
so no signal no sentence strategy said
that these distributions depend only in
Q sub s it only depends the distribution
and only depending the queries today in
s and so in other words you can think of
it I'll define this distribution as a
sim and Q s so in other words
unknowingly District a strategy is such
that there exists for any subset and any
kind of queries for this upset there's a
distribution such that for every
possible query if you the probability if
you can see if you constrain yourself to
this subset the probability and the
answer is exactly what we call sim of SM
kunis okay so this is exactly it's just
saying that this probability depends
only on s and Q sub s and we that's kind
of how we call it so this is this this
is just the definition of no singing
that we saw on the distant Phoenicians
itself sub no signaling just changes
this was an inequality so it just says
there is these distributions exactly as
before but now you require oh sorry
there's a star the star should not be
here and now we just require that this
probability is smaller so now P star
doesn't have to be a distribution it can
be a sub distribution okay so the
strategy and sub low signaling if this
strategy is a it doesn't it to be a
probability distribution it can be a sub
distribution so it can sometimes abort
and
the only requirement is that for every
ah queue if you restrict an S it's at
most this are kind of universal a
property distribution so he has more
power and the power of kind of a
boarding seems like it only lowers his
chance cuz he's just a birdie but
actually it gives them more flexibility
because he doesn't meet that we can find
that there's no signalling thing and
it's much more powerful oh so now let me
now I wanna if you condition a nun
aborting you're signaling exactly that's
why this kind of exactly okay so let me
end by showing kind of the the proof
idea in a little more detail ok so again
what we need to show is how to go from k
prove ER - to prove ER with this loss in
soundness and I'm gonna use several
singing strategies for it so you can
abort with yes I can have exactly right
so in a subtle signaling you kind of use
it
yeah then to the boy to think about it
you kind of need to be now suddenly but
you can aboard in a signalling manner
that's I think a good approximation of
the notion
Oh so let me show how we go from cater
to so actually the transformation is
very very similar to the original
transfer transformation in the original
paper of MIP okay how do we go we take K
provers and the way we go to - we give
one of them all the queries he gives us
all the answers in the classical setting
we give the other prover just one random
query and we check consistency here we
give a random subset of queries and
check consistency okay so we need a
subset here for the no signaling setting
but other than that the same the same
transformation okay and now what we
prove huh now what we prove is if in the
to prove er the no signaling value is
close to 1 then in the K prove er the
sub no signaling strategy I'm going to
think of it as also close to 1 because
I'm thinking of epsilon is very small
think of epsilon is 2 to the minus K
squared okay so I I have this 2 to the K
factor but if epsilon is smaller than 2
to the minus K squared it's kind of this
2 to the K gets even if there is
constant here in the component that
you're not seeing a square minus epsilon
is it goes to 1 opposed to 0 what's
wrong both of them are close to 1
because epsilon is smaller than 2 to the
minus K squared you should think about
you should think of Epsilon
okay but this is still like the new
single in value here is the minus K
squared up one minus of them but this is
sab no Seng with a fabulous signaling
strategy yeah so I'm saying it okay yeah
this is a theorem we'll see how to use
it we say if here you can cheat with
probability 1 minus Epsilon
then I'm gonna prove and this food is
pretty simple actually I'll try to show
it to you that the high-level idea then
you can cheat here with also with pretty
high probability but in a sub no
signaling strategy not not know
something but some so it was a powerful
cheater and then we use kind of the main
technical kind of heavy lifting theorem
that shows that actually we can convert
this you can think of this as being like
of this is still being to the minus K
squared so you can invert this internal
signal that's what you're missing
so I'm not gonna have probably time to
talk about this heavy lifting even
though I'm sad about it because that's
where all the sweat came because I can
find the what there's a lot of sweat
this theorem okay so but let me and
since I'm running out of time I'll just
show give you a few minutes of this and
we'll conclude okay so this proof is
that's all I want to say about it it's
actually very the idea is simple I'm not
gonna show the details but the idea is
very simple the idea is that if I have a
no singing strategy here that succeeds
with very high probability I'll tell you
what I'll do here so now the cheating
prover he can be suddenly he gets all
the queries what does he do well what do
you will do he will use his to prove ur
a cheater what he will do he will give
one prove all his queries and the other
prove a random subset of the queries but
he'll do that for every single subset so
he will run this prove or two to the K
times
okay so again he gets his K provers I'm
talkin and I'm constructing approver
here so he's getting all the K provers
for every possible subset he's gonna run
this pool here are all my queries and
here are subsets of my queries if even
one of them is rejecting he's gonna say
reject time to boarding so now I'm a
boarding and that's why it's a bernal
signaling because it's a lot to abort in
a signaling if all of them are accepting
then he'll just output a random one it
doesn't matter which one they're all the
same distribution cuz it's no signaling
so hard with a random answers here and
form a union bound it's pretty pretty
easy to see that you lose only one minus
two to the K and like just you lose two
to the K times epsilon what a little
more delicate is to show that it still
sub no signaling but it's also possible
if you stared enough you see that it's
the sub no signaling holes so that's it
okay so let me conclude I'll go through
this so look at all the hard work see
we had to use the result of Justin in
Lisa and see because of them were stuck
with the K squared hey there's another
reason we're stuck with the K squared
but I glossed over it fast okay so we
need to extend the probabilities it's so
signals okay some a since I don't have
time but I would love to tell you that
the real problem I don't have time
hey I can say maybe it then one one
minute if you don't have questions and
all right you can ask that question okay
but let me summarize so what we showed
is uh ah that K prove er MIP if you want
taunus and most 2 to the minus K squared
then your space bounded the spacing to
be most to the K squared so this is kind
of the the picture and we did it by
converting K poverty to prove errs via
this loss a we had the heavy-lifting
theorem that I didn't tell you anything
about a of course open problem so I
would love to understand to bridge this
gap but maybe this is kind of a
technical open problem but I think more
interesting is to understand to find
more application of applications for
this no signaling and in particular I
think sub low signaling z' strategies
can also have very interesting
applications in cryptography and in
particular maybe we can relax the
assumption if we allow more power to the
cheating provers we can use maybe mini
crypt I don't know to get a in to
encrypt these questions so so the
question is what kind of anyway find
more applications of these notions okay
and I'll end with that thank you
nothing seems to me they're not
understanding much that there there is
and the condition of no signalling but
there is help because is not the
Cartesian product it's not it's not
independent it's not right it's not a
Cartesian product now we look at the
dimension of how far is the Joint
Distribution for the contagious suppose
I give you the most active distribution
not signaling but the district a the
Joint Distribution in some are you
talking about the distribution of the
queries of the distribution of the
answers I when you say the distribution
do you mean the distribution of the
questions of the queries or the
distribution of the answers well that
doesn't make sense that their cohesion
oh I see conditioned on the queries are
the Cartesian product okay okay so okay
now I understand yeah how far they are
from Keynesian program independent this
is the original or the independent each
now we have no they are not independent
there is a Joint Distribution but we put
a condition of no signaling given the no
signaling how far is the joy mystery if
I if I say no which is in some way how
much you can help it's a good question
yeah you want a more refined version
question I haven't thought about it so I
don't know what where like if it's a
continuing or is there kind of a tipping
point I don't know any to think about it
so the question
any other questions yes Lisa what oh you
understand okay go for it
oh you didn't understand okay so the
question was essentially he said in a
local you have to be completely local in
uh no signaling you can have kind of
arbitrary and the questions can you make
a refined version and be say how close
you are to being local and try to see if
you can say something more
maybe
[Music]
so you're talking about sub no signaling
yes good that's the question that's
exactly the question the question is can
you do a like a BMW style heuristic but
start with a sub no signalling and what
in what cryptography do you need to put
in there to make it sound maybe you need
much less so that's a very good question
that's it's for me so generally works
doesn't apply
maybe you then do public verifiability
maybe you can put there something you
know any other questions
no signalling it contains what we shown
I didn't show you but what we shown this
work that with K provers it's contained
in space to the K a now if you're aiming
for it to use it with cryptography
Zaycon right so it's a good question you
can do it aim
deterministic yeah yeah deterministic
it's a it's a good question so you need
to construct this for some large faster
languages and you need some yes yes a
second what is the main do the main idea
okay so the main do I have another
second okay I have another second so how
do we go from sub no sinking to no
signalling so with subtle signalling the
only thing we know is that you're below
this kind of universal distribution of
the idea is that okay we first trunk so
I'll show you in a sec yes slide will be
easier the main idea is to
so
here okay that's what I need so we have
a sub no signaling P star what would we
do we first want to average it out get
rid of the big ones them we want to make
sure that you're always a we want to
make sure that you're always okay let me
skip this at the first step which
requires a work but I don't want to get
into that is to construct this
distributions sim s and simply like
before but I would like equality if it
was equality it's up no signal it's no
signal the first step is to generate
inequality at least inequality so for
any T that's bigger and you look at your
sub T you restrict it to s I want to say
that this is smaller I would like to say
it's equal if I can say for every T
that's bigger than s that this is equal
I would get no signaling but all I can
do is get smaller equal okay so that
kind of the first part it's kind of
technical it's not very interesting the
main interesting part is how to go from
smaller equal to equality in the way we
do it is by essentially increasing the
distribution we increase them the space
of answers even so we allow allow you to
add to add a kind of a fake symbol
question mark and allow you I want to
just lift it to go up to the same level
as sin so now I'm gonna say oh it's
below same okay so what output I'm gonna
allow this cute output a s and some I'm
trial try to lift it kind of to go all
the way to sin so we have this lifting
thing but even lifting it is it's
difficult and even better even to only
get to this we can't really do it we can
only do it for what's called in listen
justin's paper honest referee no
signaling but they show already how to
go from honest referee to no signaling
so there's a bunch of there's a lot of
ideas it's very hard to explain but
there's this lifting if I had to I had
to summarize in two sense there's this
lifting idea of to lift probability and
idea that we need to kind
of a confine ourselves Treasury yes I
don't think it's tight actually I think
I think we the K squared that we lose I
don't I don't believe it's tight in your
thing and I don't believe it's stiii
that look that's my guess but I it's
really a guess it just doesn't seem like
the right answer and when you look at
the white it seems like a but even that
it's because it seems like hey but why
do you go from one minus two to the K to
the minus K - only 2 to the minus K it's
not clear why don't you go I don't know
no you it can't preserve there because
if you do if it's too close then it will
imply that look we can't go from k plus
two to pores because kpop many purposes
is excellent at space-based so you have
to have air but I think we're losing too
much it's a good question depends on I
don't know you're saying wait to where
you so you're asking if how much you
need to improve to get like a good
application I don't know the answer so
we just say this is a there's a lot of
question this work raises much more
questions than one it answers ok thank
you
[Applause]